today we're talking about the planet
mercury the closest planet to the Sun
and the smallest planet in our solar
system
actually it's smaller than some of the
moons in our solar system so it's
smaller than Ganymede it's only a little
bit bigger than Earth's moon itself so a
mercury year the time it takes for
mercury to go around the Sun is 88 Earth
days so if you lived on Mercury you
would be much older than you are on
earth yeah there's this very strange
thing about mercury that it actually
rotates very slowly and so a day the
time it takes the planet to rotate once
is very long can pay compared to a year
and the time it takes to actually go
around the Sun and so a day but well
there's this strange effect that that
for every twice that you go round round
the Sun the planet rotates three times
so three days on Mercury is the same as
two years and it's not just
approximately true it's exactly true
it's exactly true that it goes around
exactly three times rotates exactly
three times where every twice it orbits
around the Sun and this is a phenomenon
called resonance where you have this
matching up of things exactly in integer
numbers well related to one another is
in resonance it's the same kind of thing
as with the moon going around the earth
that the moon rotates exactly once as a
one day for every year for every time it
goes around the earth which is why we
always see the same face of the moon
towards us but the case in mercury is
kind of a bit subtler because it's not a
one-to-one resonance is what's called a
three-to-two resonance it rotates three
times for every twice it goes around so
if you standing on Mercury you see the
Sun in the sky for almost six months as
it rises really slowly then just hangs
out there and then moves down you
wouldn't have a blue sky because you
don't have any atmosphere to scatter the
photons but you would be able to see
distant stars so you'd have kind of a
nighttime sky but you'd still have
illumination from the Sun so you'd still
be bright you'd still have a shadow you
just wouldn't have a blue sky like what
we saw when the men walked on the moon
yeah exactly like what we saw when the
men walked on the moon so the basic idea
is that planets go around the Sun
following ellipses something one of the
things that Kepler figured out over a
long time ago but it's not quite true if
you really had a point like planet going
around a point like Sun they would
indeed follow exactly ellipses but
because planets aren't exactly point
like and there are other planets all
perturbing their orbits and so on they
don't actually follow exactly ellipses
in about the mid-1800s people were
trying to map out the orbits of planets
based on
Newtonian physics and we did very well
predicting the moon's orbit and Mars
orbit and Venus's but Mercury's for some
reason was a little strange it was off
from what Newtonian physics predicted
and so this actually led people to
suggest that there might actually be
another planet that was perturbing the
orbit of mercury that was even closer to
the Sun so people came up with the idea
that there was this planet called Vulcan
even closer to the Sun that was actually
causing it but then people searched for
this planet and couldn't find it and it
turned out that the answer was it was
general relativity because general
relativity says the laws of gravity
you've been using the Newtonian laws of
gravity aren't quite right and when you
put in what's known as the
post-newtonian correction which is just
kind of starting to put general
relativity into the laws of gravity you
find actually you can explain all these
difference between the orbit you
actually see in the orbit you're
expecting to see so this was one of the
very first pieces of actual evidence for
the validity of Einstein's general
theory of relativity
so what Newton says was happen is right
but only in the limit when gravity isn't
very strong so when there's very weak
things going on Newtonian gravity is
pretty much spot-on what general
relativity says is that when gravity
starts getting stronger then you get
further and further away from that
Newtonian or gravity and so you're so
fit now with the with the case of
Mercury gravity starting to get that
little bit stronger because the two are
a bit closer together and so you start
seeing the very subtle first effects of
general relativity
so Newtonian gravity is kind of a limit
that works part of the time but general
relativity is kind of the big picture
that works all the time we have sent a
couple spacecraft to Mercury the first
one was in the 70s
it's called Mariner 10 and it did a
couple orbits around and took images and
sent it back but actually there was an
entire side of mercury that we weren't
able to see with that spacecraft so we
recently NASA recently sent another one
called the messenger and it took off in
2004 and it's been traveling since then
and just last year it arrived so it's
been doing a few close passes around
mercury and it will eventually orbit in
2011 so through the messenger we've been
able to see really high resolution
images of the crater structures some of
the craters when these impactors come
and they land on the planet a lot of
material gets shot up and then it
spreads these bright Ray's around
so we can see evidence for that on
Mercury and there's not any activity
happening to erase those effects
actually messenger just saw evidence for
Vulcan volcanic activity on Mercury
mercury is very close to the Sun always
and it's very close to the Sun in our
sky so whenever you try to look for it
it's always going to be very close to to
the Sun so you can just see it right
before the Sun sets or just before the
Sun rises and so since it passes around
the Sun very often it passes in front of
the Sun which you can only see with very
fancy filters and things like that but
this is what we call a transit when
mercury actually passes right in front
of the Sun at night time on Mercury the
part of the planet that is not facing
the Sun when it's the farthest away from
the Sun is actually very cold so it's
minus 180 degrees Celsius and when the
planet is the closest to the Sun and the
part that's facing the Sun the daytime
part is actually very hot so it's 430
degrees Celsius do you want to take that
umbrella no I certainly wouldn't need
this umbrella if I went to mercury
there's no atmosphere no clouds no
anything that would cause me to not have
a nice day
[Laughter]